i think that economic populism is
actually something that you know if you
look at it and going back to what we're
just talking about with the vaccine
mandates you're seeing a lot of this
populist energy
find and make strange bedfellows right
city right now this past weekend
there was an anti-vaccine march by a
group of maga supporters in staten
island but then there was also an
anti-vaccine protest in brooklyn by
black lives matter and yet if you listen
to some of the things that they were
saying it was almost the exact same
phrases and yet here are two groups that
are supposed to be you know in mortal
opposition to one another and yet
they're both agreed that's that it is
and you know sort of not a you versus we
but it's an us it's an up down thing
it's not a left-right thing
when is china going to become democratic
you look at
the history of tiananmen square and
certainly you know they had a point
where it seemed like it might be on the
cusp of happening
my theory though is that the opposite
happened because the chinese communist
party went through the tiananmen squares
uh massacre they went through and this
is the key difference between the fall
of communism in the soviet union and
tiananmen in china
in the soviet union in moscow
the soldiers refused to fire on the
citizens when they were protesting they
refused in china
the tanks rolled mm-hmm
we've all seen it right we don't even
need to go go through any more of that
and so this created a situation where
the regime was then able to stay in
power but they also realized that they
couldn't just keep the people in abject
poverty because
this created too much of a mishmash they
were going to have this foreign direct
investment that had started been started
in the 1970s so what were they to do so
they embark on this new strategy where
they have corporate power
from the west and they have the
authoritarian regime of the of the ccp
on top
and so what it created was a situ a new
type of of government that really hasn't
been seen
uh on on the face of the planet since
you know the time of the great you know
mercantile empires of the past where
they said look there's going to be no
democracy there's going to be pure
authoritarianism but we will allow a
market to operate underneath us as long
as you don't threaten our political
power this is what the ccp became
so american elites when they would go
over american politicians or
congressional delegations and i would
see them when i was in shanghai when
they would come over they would say wow
your guy's system is really good you
don't have to worry about any of that
free speech stuff if you want to
high-speed rail maglev you just knock
down all the houses and what about the
people get rid of them you know move
them away who cares how long they look
if you're a hundred years a thousand
years who cares your village is in my
way oh if you want to build the three
gorgeous damn well just
flood all those towns who cares let's
build a giant lake we need this because
progress is the only thing that matters
to us
and so you take those two forms and put
them together it's intoxicating it is it
is a form of absolute power it is
intoxicating and my theory of the case
is that in america our elites our ruling
class the one percent whatever you call
it and if you actually look at it the
one percent of america
it's uh you know that that phrase right
it used to be in the occupy movement but
the chinese communist party they're
about one percent of the chinese
population as well slightly less um but
i crunched the numbers on it and so it
really is what you have to do is you
have to look away from the elites in
society but if you take you know i guess
you call them the deplorables or just
the american people as a whole the
people that aren't making money that
aren't profiting off this system and you
put them together with in in china the
cognate would be the la baijing which
means the old hundred names you know the
sort of like the same burgeoning middle
class lower class and china they don't
have middle class like we do um you put
that together and you say
hey these guys are screwing you
these guys are screwing you they're
robbing you blind right you know they're
all getting rich one side gets the
wealth but the wealth doesn't trickle
down in china because of their
authoritarian system the one side in the
u.s they're getting the wealth but all
you're all you're becoming is a consumer
right you get your cheap chinese tv your
cheap cell phone whatever it is but you
don't get the wealth right you don't get
any benefits you don't get the jobs you
don't get the secondary tertiary
industries that would come off having a
private primary income driver and this
is why the vast heartland of the united
states has been completely hollowed out
you know i'm from
not the heartland but you know one of
these sort of post-industrial cities in
the northeast and it's the exact same
situation right this is the reason the
rust belt exists is because of this and
it's not elite capture it's not main
train candidate it's nothing like that
it's a merger that's what i'm trying to
get people understand it's actually a
merger at the highest level
so what do we do
so what do we do well good luck with all
of that
you have to decouple right you have to
you have to decouple and you have to say
you have to come to it from a
perspective and i've been i've been
looking at this thing for 15 years right
um i first went to china in 2006. i
moved there in 2007 lived there for two
years learned the language when the
military afterwards
primary focus was china um
it it you know it's and i'd be in these
rooms in the intel community and we'd be
talking about like the south china sea
and we'd be talking about oh they're
building these islands and they're
militarizing the islands and got this
aircraft carrier and it's going to be
coming in it's going to be doing
operations what do we do we'll send a
message yeah yeah we'll send a strongly
worded message we'll we'll get the
united nations involved right we'll get
the
three-part talks five-part talks and i
and i would be the guy in the back
saying you know
i mean that's that's nice but you know i
you know i don't think we're planning to
go to war with china i certainly hope we
aren't but you know unless you use
economic leverage isn't
what they listen it's the only thing
they're going to answer to so
you that's what you have to break up you
have to break up that merger you have to
get people to understand that you are
being screwed that you are being robbed
blind and you have to then turn on the
economic experience but i don't care if
it's a republican a democrat or other
that does it right it's just what's good
for the people on both sides of of the
the world in this case both sides of the
pacific it's going to be better if you
break this up you start actually having
real diplomacy and not these these
quasi-transnational organizations
anymore right but is there any chance i
mean that this administration or even if
we got an america a repub american that
was a hell of a freudian slip a
republican administration um is there
any chance that america could actually
do that i mean i certainly don't see it
under biden that we could ever
not no i guess we could do it but that
we would ever exert the type of
influence that you're talking about
i i think it's there i think there's i
think that economic populism is actually
something that you know if you look at
it and going back to what we're just
talking about with the vaccine mandates
you're seeing a lot of this populist
energy find and make strange bedfellows
right look city right now this past
weekend
there was an anti-vaccine march by a
group of maga supporters in staten
island but then there was also an
anti-vaccine protest in brooklyn by
black lives matter and yet if you listen
to some of the things that they were
saying it was almost the exact same
phrases and yet here are two groups that
are supposed to be you know in mortal
opposition to one another and yet
they're both agreed that's that it is
and you know sort of not a you versus we
but it's an us versus it's an up-down
thing it's not a left-right thing and so
i think the more people start to talk
about economic populism the less that
people talk about some of these more
caustic politicized issues
i actually think that you there are
potentials for a coalition to be built
across
parties across nations of people coming
together and saying look we don't want
to be ruled by a transnational fight you
know elite anymore we just we don't want
it we we want to be countries again we
want to be citizens again we want to
have real diplomacy um you're france you
know france is is standing up right now
and kind of thumbing their nose at uh
at biden they pulled their ambassador
which is like the first time in history
that i think that's ever done and i
think that's it in a sense i think it's
good because
as the us you know because the u.s is
losing it's its position right it's
certainly losing its position as the
global hegemon if you will
then uh it's going to require alliances
and it's going to require
actual diplomacy and sitting down with
people that we want to have actual help
with in mutual aid do you you can't have
any more of this you know we're going to
invade iraq and you have to come along
because we said so right or else we're
going to pull this that and that
everything no no we're not going to do
that anymore it has to be actual
mutually assured benefit we always
talking about usually for destruction
why don't we talk about mutually short
benefit if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell